[Music]
I feel like I've always loved attention
I mean like when I was younger I was
always bullied so when I started you
know shifting and growing up and and
dance especially like really opened me
up out of my show I would say I
definitely loved the attention of like
being able to perform in front of people
and like entertain and like you know
have people be inspired by that
[Music]
I would say I'm like a multi-faceted
Creator so like a lot of people know me
for dancing family content some as a
gamer I'm kind of like an all-around
Entertainer in general so anything
that's entertaining I kind of dabble in
started off watching the OG YouTubers
like Ryan Higa he was like the main main
one honestly KevJumba PewDiePie all of
those people like the ogs you know and I
pretty much just always saw them making
really dope videos and making a career
out of it I was like this is crazy like
and I never wanted to do a nine to five
I was always like entrepreneur kind of
like minded because my parents were both
like owners of like their own businesses
and stuff
the main one that they had was a nail
salon I kind of helped my mom with the
salon I was like either like a front
desk person or I was uh working with my
dad and is like screen printing
embroidery shop so I was doing that for
a year and for me I was like okay social
media looks like it could be a business
they're doing it so I was like why can't
I and so by 2015 I decided I was like yo
okay I'm gonna do it doesn't matter how
long it takes this is what I love to do
2015 I started 2016 a year in I popped
off a lot a bit you know I did my own
little viral Trend and that got me my
first like summer followers and that was
when it hit me I was like okay this is
working I just have to keep going and
push at it and then the money slowly
started coming in it wasn't enough to
completely like stop like my my actual
jobs and stuff but it was a it was a
cool little side hustle that was like
you know it was starting to work
[Music]
I dropped out after sophomore year and
from there I was able to focus on my
passions which was dancing being helping
a content creator I was a very good like
scholar I was very like straight A's
dual enrollment kid kind of thing and I
I was like doing really well at school
but by the time I was a sophomore I had
like senioritis and since my dad needed
help with the shop he told me to like
leave it and I was like yeah of course
I'll help out I'm down yeah and then by
2019 that's when Tick Tock happened Tick
Tock changed for musically
and the algorithm was like completely
different that first week I hopped on I
literally gained a million followers at
and and for me that was my first million
on any platform I stuck at it and like
literally by like three or four months I
was like 10 million followers and then
it was just up from there
my mom actually worked and owned her own
nail salon until 2020 and then I told
her to just drop it that was when
obviously I kind of blew up with social
media moved to LA my income pretty much
like 100x so I had uh her and my
siblings move out with me and we've been
out here ever since
Jonathan Daniel so I'm gonna clap my
hands and you guys are gonna drag it
this way
to me
yes
I want you guys to struggle
three two action
oh
yeah yeah
what what was this is this another box
from Chipotle
look at that today we're going to be
unboxing
pouring my family at 22 is surreal but
it's it's also like you know I don't
think about it too much but it is really
cool it's still because I know that my
family has worked really hard to just
support especially in the Asian culture
like it's very sacrifice everything to
make sure that the family is good the
kids are good and all it so being able
to kind of give back especially earlier
on is is really cool and I feel like
we're able to now focus on a lot more
like family things
I involved my family a lot of my content
mainly because one that's fun I'm able
to make whatever I want so I think being
able to share experiences with them and
do things that I typically wouldn't do
on a normal day is is really cool
second thing is like being able to build
a brand an opportunity for them to to
use it for their own once they grow up
and you know they want to do other
things so for my brothers my sister for
my mom it's like social media is is this
a tool you know uh and and I want to be
able to like give them the best
opportunity as possible so that if say
my little brothers eventually grow up to
want to be actors it's easier to have a
platform and kind of grow from there or
if my sister wants to get into makeup or
you know whatever the case may be it's
just it's just a lot easier when you
have that foot in the door already and
it's kind of like established thanks to
police
cool
the first big deal I had was probably
with bang energy I I worked with them I
believe in like 2017 or 2018 and they
they had this deal structure of like
they would pay me based off of views and
this was on Instagram every video was
based off of like okay it was like 100
000 views it's D if it's a million views
it's like a rank s here right so it's
just like a range between those and
they'll pay me like a few hundred to a
few thousand dollars so I used to get
about like 250k views average on my
dance videos so what I did and I
experimented with it I actually put
AdSense into my videos and I was able to
put like two three hundred dollars make
the video go viral it would hit like
over a million views and then they would
pay me like x amount of dollars and it
would like pay back way more than what I
put in so I was doing that for about
like eight to ten months and then yeah
that was that was my first big like
situation where I could I made almost I
would say like 50 to like 80k in that
year from that deal on
I'm in here to basically shoot my second
Channel content where I'm like sitting
down and on the you know to sit down
chilling type of thing or gaming videos
and then if I turn around I got my just
met a set and I do all this stuff here
I turn this on
all right I think this is Yep this is in
me there you go and then
I control it myself
so I'll start recording now already
joystick
bam
here's how you can be a part of the web
3 Revolution and the good news is that
you don't need to be some tech genius
like Mark Zuckerberg or have tons of
money web3 is the next version of the
internet where normal people like Yumi
will own it and not just the big social
media companies like today
so good
crazy
joystick is a very big dream passion of
mine it's uh the Next Generation
ecosystem for gamers and it's pretty
much an opportunity I want to bring to
the world where I know that there's this
new space of web3 and gaming called play
to earn where people can literally make
like income in like an actual
sustainable career out of playing video
games I saw like a little glimpse of it
with web 3 games already and there's
already people I know of that have
stories of literally them supporting
their families just based off of this
and I was like this is the future and I
love technology I love like you know
futuristic things like ready player one
so I was like this is like one step
closer to that feature
I first learned about all of this from
garyvee I bought my first crypto Punk
because of him and then I think like I
heard a couple of people saying like oh
it's a bubble we don't know what's gonna
happen so I actually I actually told it
on accident and a few months later I
forgot about the whole Market I come
back to find out that crypto punks blew
up and I missed out on like I think 700
000 of profit
so I was like oh let me get into this
let me not miss out on anything so my
phone moved into the market pretty much
[Music]
with joystick my my first steps is to
educate I want to basically provide them
like all the tools they need to turn
into esport players content creators
streamers just like different events to
allow them to actually earn financially
and basically just kind of grow our
family and kind of learn and evolve with
the space because the space is so new
still so I'm just trying to have it to
where we kind of all tread through the
the space together
I saw that the web 3 space needed this
and that gaming is going to evolve into
this regardless I think that so many
people game and technology is just going
to get more advanced we already have
gaming streamers we already have you
know esport players why not being able
to actually make money just playing the
game in general
[Music]
foreign
concept I gotta think Concepts are good
all right put on the white shirt and
then unzip it
go
200. yeah
we're not doing any effects for this
yeah no the only effect in my eye
so I'll have Bravo do the I think just
the eye yeah
[Music]
I think that if you want to go down the
influencer path you have to look at what
makes you happy opposed to
the results or the success you know I
think that so many people especially now
they have this like really weird
short-term mindset where if it doesn't
work out for them in a few months they
they just like get discouraged I think
that if you want to get into this this
is a long game you know this is
something that I even have to remind
myself that it's like
if I do this in five years or ten years
and I still
I'm nowhere near blowing up or viral or
whatever the case may be like am I still
going to be happy
I think that Tick Tock is established
itself really well I think that it's
going to stay and it's going to be there
for a long time the the algorithm the
way that it's structured works really
well in the last few years we've been
able to see a lot more diverse creators
come into the scene and I think it
inspires more because for me being able
to see that someone that kind of you
know looked like me or resembled me
Asian representation in general has
inspired me to want to push forward
it's just been really cool to see like a
lot of our cultures finally being
appreciated and and people realizing you
know anime is super cool like y'all are
late to the game so like you're like
pranking me like
and you keep missing like oh oh my gosh
okay go oh
my ideal life would definitely be just
me still doing what I love and if I want
to make content I can if I don't want to
I don't have to
kind of just having not just Financial
Freedom but freedom to kind of get into
any field I want
in the last three years like my whole
life has changed so much and like my
passions have changed as well
I'm able to support my family I'm able
to do what I love being appreciative and
like knowing that like not a lot of
people have that opportunity there's no
rush
[Music]